Adolph Arthur “Harpo” Marx was a brilliant,
delightful, completely original comedian.
Any fan of the Marx brothers and the wonderful
movies (as I am) knows this.
In the Marx brothers movies, Harpo played
a childlike character, a kind of ethereal
spirit who lived in his own world.
He wore a curly wig, a big raincoat, a plug
hat, and he went around honking a big taxi
horn.
And of course, he loved to play the harp.
Harpo never spoke in the Marx brothers films,
existing as a happy-go-lucky mute in a world
of voices and sound.
In real life, Harpo had a few childlike characteristics
too.
For instance, he was a grown man who was completely
comfortable in public without clothing on
(much like a young child.)
This is probably why there are more “Harpo
Marx naked stories” than any other comedian,
a few of the more amusing of which I’ll
presently share.
The first Harpo naked story involves Harpo
and his brother, Groucho.
Harpo and Groucho were going to attend an
all-male “stag party” in a hotel.
As they entered the hotel elevator, they were
each carrying an empty suitcase.
Why?
As a gag, they thought it would be hilarious
to walk out of the elevator nude and surprise
the guys.
Thus, they stopped the elevator and quickly
undressed and put all their clothes in suitcases.
However, in their excitement, they pushed
the wrong floor number and walked in, completely
naked, to an all-women bridal shower.
In the late 1920s, Harpo met the classic writer
Somerset Maugham.
As Maugham was giving Harpo a tour of his
house, Harpo saw that Maugham had a swimming
pool right below his bedroom window.
Inspired to go for a swim, and wanting to
take advantage of this excellent opportunity
afforded by the house design, Harpo stripped
off his clothes and leaped out the window
into the pool.
During this same period, Harpo was scheduled
to have dinner with the famed writer George
Bernard Shaw.
Relaxing before the meal, Harpo was swimming
in the nude down on a beach, when he heard
voices up above him.
He threw a towel around himself, climbed the
hill above and realized it was Bernard Shaw’s
voice he’d heard.
Harpo put out his hand to shake the great
author’s, when Bernard Shaw got a mischievous
smile on his face and snatched away Harpo’s
towel, leaving Harpo standing au naturel.
“From the first moment I met George Bernard
Shaw, I had nothing to hide,” quipped Harpo.
When the Marx brothers were filming their
movie “Horsefeathers” in 1932, they were
shooting a scene featuring the movie’s big,
climactic football game.
After several takes, the huge stadium crowd
of extras was growing restless and disinterested.
“I’ll wake them up,” Harpo reportedly
said.
He then proceeded to take off all his clothes
and ran laps around the stadium completely
in the buff.
When the Marx brothers went to MGM Studios
to make movies in 1935, they had a hard time
getting in to see producer Irving Thalberg.
Although they had scheduled meetings, Thalberg
kept them waiting outside several times and
the boys got fed up.
Thus, they decided to sneak in when he temporarily
left his office.
When Thalberg returned, he discovered all
three Marx brothers (Harpo, Groucho, and Chico)
sitting naked on the floor of his office.
Not just naked, the boys had started a little
fire in the fireplace and they sat roasting
potatoes over it.
A good sport, Thalberg told them to get some
butter from the studio commissary, which Harpo
did, and they all ate the potatoes together.
(It was not recorded whether Harpo put on
his clothes before going to the commissary.)
Incidentally, after this incident, Thalberg
reportedly never kept the boys waiting again.
After Harpo married in 1936, he and his wife
Susan tried to adopt children.
During one adoption process, the lady who
interviewed Harpo and his wife rubbed Harpo
the wrong way.
He may have been offended by her anti-semitism,
but Harpo, uncharacteristically, was very
angry.
On the next scheduled meeting, she came to
the Marx household and rang the doorbell.
Naturally, Harpo answered the door completely
naked, but with a bow tied around his manhood.
For the record, though, the couple were able
to adopt four children, Minnie, Alex, Jimmy,
and Bill.
When asked how many children he was going
to adopt, Harpo stated, “I’d like to adopt
as many children as I have windows in my house.
So when I leave for work, I want a kid in
every window, waving goodbye.”
In his later years, Harpo lived a happy life
of semi-retirement in palm springs.
Harpo loved to play golf in the palm springs
heat (in fact when he died his ashes were
sprinkled over the seventh hole’s sandtrap
at the Rancho Mirage golf course).
It should be noted, though, that his golf
routine was quite unusual, but fitting.
The elderly Harpo loved to play a bit, then
strip off all his clothes and jump into the
nearest palm springs swimming pool to refresh
himself from the desert heat.
He’d dress himself again and play a few
more holes before repeating.
Harpo’s Palm Springs neighbors, aware of
their aged uninvited “pool guest”, never
complained.
It seems everyone knew Harpo and loved him
for his unique eccentricities.
Speaking of golf, one of Harpo’s goals towards
the end of his life was to make the first
naked hole-in-one.
He would bring a bucket of golf balls, take
off all his clothes, and hit them, one after
the other, toward a hole.
Unfortunately, in spite of his trying and
trying, he fell short (supposedly within a
foot on one shot) of achieving his naked golf
ambition.
Mr. Rogers was a vegetarian.
He didn’t smoke or drink or seem to have
any major vices.
He also stayed married to the same woman until
his death; their marriage lasted 47 years.
Why am I talking about Mr. Rogers in an article
about Harpo Marx’ propensity to drop his
drawers in public?
About the only even slightly “scandalous”
thing Mr. Rogers seemed to do (with an emphasis
on “slightly”), which he revealed in an
interview, was that he swam laps completely
in the buff nearly every morning of his adult
life at various clubs that allowed nude swimming
at certain times of the day.
As to why exactly he did this instead of wear
a swim suit, this isn’t know, but it’s
thought it was simply because public swimming
pools nearly always used to require people
to swim in the buff due to the cloth commonly
used in old swimming suits having fibers that
would clog up the pool filters (think wool).
Today, with modern materials and pool cleaning
systems this isn’t an issue, but perhaps
as he always did it as a young man, he simply
decided to continue as an old, despite it
no longer being necessary.